mr president from utah ask unanimous
consent to suspend the quorum call
without objection
some of our nation's finest answered the
call of duty here in our nation's
capital over the last two weeks
to assist with the peaceful transition
of power and make sure that it was in
fact peaceful
these dedicated men and women in the
national guard
have taken an oath to protect that
bedrock document the constitution of the
united states
and indeed they have fulfilled
that duty some of our very finest
in the national guard came here
to serve from my home state of utah
321 troops that have discharged their
duties
with distinction and honor came from the
utah national guard
the majority of task force utah uh
consisted
of soldiers from the second battalion
222nd field artillery 65th
fires brigade also known as the triple
deuce additional soldiers came from the
204th maneuver enhancement brigade
and the 19th special forces group
airborne
i rise today to honor and thank these
really selfless women and men
these past weeks the utah guardsmen were
stationed at the madison building
of the library of congress just across
the street from the capitol
many of these soldiers it was their
first time ever visiting
washington dc major brent mangum of the
utah national guard remarked
that as the soldiers were stationed at
buildings
or they saw these quotes
on the walls quotes from our founding
fathers
and as they were working in these
buildings
you could see them pausing during the
day reading the quotes
and then stopping to reflect on them
i myself had the great privilege uh
in a couple of different groups
to give some of these men and women a
tour of the capitol building
before they left to go back to utah
it was a great honor to meet and get to
know these
dedicated guardsmen and to learn from
their stories
and to see firsthand their caliber as
people
and most importantly perhaps their
visible commitment
to the united states of america this
idea this principle this great land of
ours the greatest civilization human
history has ever known
was something that they're independently
committed
to defending and protecting even at the
sacrifice
of their own security and their own ease
which they would have otherwise enjoyed
over the last couple of weeks
one of the most remarkable things about
these citizen soldiers
is the way in which they tirelessly
serve their communities and i
say that meaning both inside and outside
of their guard duty my salt lake city
office was lucky enough to have
one of these fine young soldiers alfredo
lopez
as an intern a few years ago alfredo
immigrated with his family
from peru at the age of 10
and they began to build a life here in
the united states
in addition to serving the people of
utah and my state office he's
also on active duty was on active duty
with the marine corps
before he joined the national guard
alfredo
in all of his endeavors in our country
has sought only to give back he's
grateful for his country and wants to
make sure that it's a
strong safe secure place in which to
live
another guardsman who is here g
bartholomew is a prison guard
at the gunnison prison in sanpete county
utah
the son of my friend scott bartholomew a
county commissioner
in sanpete county jay has followed
his family's footsteps to serve
his local community other guardsmen
in utah are engaged in their communities
in all sorts of ways
some are teachers some are firefighters
some are policemen some are medical
professionals you name it
they've done it and many have now
answered the call of duty
on the front lines of another crisis as
our nation
faces the current pandemic these
guardsmen
have played a significant role in
providing testing
moving and storing personal protective
equipment
and other support missions to assist the
utah department of health's covet 19
response
now utah governor spencer cox has
entrusted them with another critical
mission
the guard will be on the front lines to
help ramp up the delivery
of vaccines in our state the guard has
put together teams that can mobilize
throughout utah
to deliver vaccinations and antibody
infusions within a matter of hours
and save a whole lot of lives and
prevent a whole lot of suffering in the
process
i've got no doubt that they will
continue to administer this duty
with dedication and with excellence just
as they do with every other assignment
with which
they're tasked in everything they do
members of the utah national guard seek
to serve and strengthen our communities
our country and our state and we're all
better off for it
it's been such an honor to have these
selfless men and women
in our nation's capital i've enjoyed
getting to know them
and look forward to visiting with them
again soon and i thank
them for their service
now mr president i'd like to discuss
another important matter
this past week we marked the anniversary
of a deadly day in american history
that has resulted in the loss of
millions of innocent
american lives that is the anniversary
of roe vs wade since january 22
1973 more than
60 million unborn children
have been lost to the scourge of
abortion
this week we honor and remember those
lives as well as those
who have been hurt by the pains of
abortion
in a normal year tens of thousands of
americans would be marching down
constitution avenue this friday
to do so this year
as with so many other things the march
for life
will instead be virtual but nonetheless
americans will continue to march whether
virtually or
in person where they can
the theme of this year's march is
together strong
life unites a fitting theme
following a year rife with division
violence and loss
now more than ever we must unite as a
nation
turning with hope towards the future
hope that our nation will heal hope
that justice will prevail hope that the
grievous act of abortion will be
forsaken
and given our country's history
in which we've stubbornly made mistakes
but thankfully come around in the end
there's much reason for hope but
we cannot heal and we cannot unite
if we don't honor and respect all of the
american people born
and unborn so many of the deepest
injustices in our country's history have
stemmed from
one dark dangerous thing
that is when we've rejected the dignity
of the human person when we've denied
the humanity of our brothers and sisters
when we've discriminated
against others based on the way they
look think
love or worship and when
because of that we've looked at them
not as people but as things
as mere objects to be acted upon
as abolitionist william lord garrison
put it the worst kind of oppression
to be regarded with the greatest degree
of indignation and abhorrence
is that which turns a man into a thing
now we've discriminated against a whole
class of people not based on the color
of their skin but on
their age and development
but it doesn't change the truth the
truth is that a baby inside the womb can
respond to human touch
by the age of eight weeks and feel pain
by the age of
20 weeks who can recognize her mother's
voice even before she is born
who has a perfect little nose
fingernails
and a beating fully functioning heart
her own distinct unique dna
and her own unique unrepeatable soul
science and medicine are only confirming
what we know deep down that unborn human
beings are in fact
little persons the evidence is only
getting planar
by the day but when we deny the humanity
of our brothers
and sisters as we've seen throughout our
history
and over the past year the inevitable
and tragic result
is violence abortion
does undeniable violence to the baby
and undeniable violence to the mother
thankfully looking back at the past
decade we've made
significant strides toward building a
culture that respects
and values and even protects all human
life even
in its simplest earliest stages of
development
many states have ensured that public
schools or
uh and uh public funds rather are
directed toward pregnancy
pregnancy helps centers rather than
abortion facilities providing
life-affirming alternatives to families
in need
and in just the last decade alone states
have passed
more than 400 pro-life laws more than
one-third of all pro-life laws
that states have passed since roe versus
wade was decided
this is indeed reason for hope
mr president through our laws and with
our lives
we ought to affirm the truth that the
lives of both the mother
and the baby matter and that health care
should
heal protect and preserve both
of those lives i've introduced
legislation to help our laws affirm that
very truth through my bill the abortion
is not health care act
we have the chance to stop the tax
deductibility of abortions which are
currently
categorized as medical care by the irs
because we must be serious whatever else
it may be of course elective abortion is
not health care
that's why physicians literally take an
oath to do no harm
the government should not offer tax
benefits for a procedure that kills
hundreds of thousands of unborn children
each and every year
and we also have a chance to prematurely
stop the use of american foreign aid
uh the the the opportunity uh
permanently
to stop the use of american foreign
foreign aid from funding
or promoting abortions overseas
perpetuating violence against women
and children abroad
especially baby girls
the protecting life and foreign
assistance act
will save countless lives across the
globe
and it affirms the truth that the lives
of all
unborn children regardless of where
they're from have dignity and worth
as the lyrics of a children's song
in my church a song that i sang in
sunday school as a child say
about each one of us i am a child
of god we are all one human family
all children of god these littlest among
us too
who cannot yet sing for themselves
but they will soon they will
soon thank you mr president i yield the
floor
absence of cool
clerk will call the role ms baldwin
mr president senator from wyoming uh
thank you mr president unanimous consent
that the quorum club initiated
without objection thank you mr president
uh mr president in the 2020 elections
americans chose an evenly divided senate
half republican half democrats evenly
divided
since the vice president is able to
break a tie
when it comes to specifically organizing
the senate
democrats have the majority now
some democrats want to lower the
threshold for all the votes
so that to pass anything all they would
need to do
in case of a thai vote would have the
vice president
be the tiebreaker
that is the way that a majority works
when there is a tie
and the vice president is of one party
they get to break the tie
in that direction of course
what we need to make sure of mr
president though is that
there is fairness in the process the
the traditions and how this institution
works
are that we have something called a
filibuster 60 votes
is how legislation is passed
and you know we know that
the press sometimes folks in congress
say it's hard to pass a law
well it's not supposed to be easy it
takes discussion takes negotiation
it brings people together i mean that's
the idea of needing 60 votes to bring
people together to get a bipartisan
consensus so that
all voices are heard that there is a
majority
of the and the minority voice is heard
and it forces us to find common ground
frankly i think there's a little there's
too little of finding common ground in
washington
already so the last thing america needs
is even more divisiveness this is a big
diverse country
we don't need 50 of the country plus one
to run roughshod over all the others
that's why our founders were so careful
to protect
the rights of the minority that's why
they created the bill of rights why they
created the electoral college it's
why they created the united states
senate the founding fathers didn't want
the senate to be a
copy of the house we're intended to be a
check
on the house that's the story that
president washington compared to
the senate to a saucer used to cool down
a cup of tea
president madison compared it to a fence
we're not supposed to be a smaller
version of the house of representatives
the senate is supposed to cool things
down we're supposed to think things
through
we're supposed to stop bad ideas and
stop the house from moving too fast
changing the rules of the senate would
make that impossible
lowering the bar to 50 votes would also
be a blatant power grab
with just 50 votes and the vice
president the democrats could even add
states to the union specifically states
that would elect
more democrats to the senate it would
give them even
more senate seats could even give them a
permanent majority
in the senate with 50 plus
votes plus the vice president democrats
could also pack the supreme court with
liberal activist judges
judges who legislate from the bench not
judges who apply the law
as written give them a permanent
majority both in the senate and on the
court
with a single rule change one branch of
government and one chamber of congress
could be under permanent democrat
control
so it's no surprise that that's tempting
to senate democrats
and the far left branch of that party is
demanding that that occur
uh you'll remember mr president that
when president trump was in office
republicans had a chance to do exactly
the same thing
in fact former president trump
repeatedly asked us and told us that we
should do just that
in one particularly memorable example he
tweeted
the u.s senate should switch to 51 votes
said the dems would do it no doubt more
than 30 different times president trump
asked that republicans and the
filibuster
we didn't we stuck to the intentions of
our founding fathers
we protected the rights of the minority
and we put country before party
democrats won't stop the power grab for
the good of the country
then they should at least do it for
their own good democrats have
only had 50 votes in the vice president
for a few days
back when democrats were in the minority
33 democrat senators said they didn't
want to change the rules
they signed a letter and that letter
called for the preservation of the
rights of the minority
27 of those democrats are still members
of the senate today
one of those democrats is now the vice
president of the united states
vice president kamel harris
even president biden called the idea of
eliminating the filibuster
a very dangerous move the white house
press secretary told us last week that
president biden still
opposes changing the rules if democrats
go down this road and break the rules of
the senate
they're doing more than just hurting the
institution they're admitting that their
ideas don't have broad
bipartisan support think about it
if the democrats agenda had the support
of the american people then they
wouldn't need
to change the rules democrats could find
bipartisan support to pass their tax
increases
they'd leave the rules alone democrats
could find bipartisan support to pass
the green new deal and the
higher energy costs that come with it
they'd leave
the rules alone if they could restrict
gun ownership
they'd leave the rules alone they can't
and they know they can't
they know the american people have
looked at their progressive agenda
and said no thank you president biden's
inaugural address last week
talked a lot about unity he said that
with unity we can do great things and i
agree
i ask my democrat colleagues if they
agree with the president's inaugural
address
or do they really think that they want
to make the united states
senate more partisan more divided
do they really want to take power away
from individual senators and give it to
whoever has 50 votes and the tiebreaker
at the moment
if it's hard for democrats to pass laws
then they should try talking with us
propose bipartisan solutions to our
nation's challenges persuade your
colleagues make progress
together as my friend former senator
lamar alexander said in his farewell
address just a month ago
he said we don't need a change of rules
the senate needs a change of behavior so
i urge my democrat colleagues to reject
a blatant power grab
stop this rush to take more and more
power
come to the center reach across the
aisle find common ground
senate republicans are ready to work
together to help the american people
to get people back to work to get our
kids safely back to school so they don't
fall further behind and to get the
coronavirus
behind us join us let's work together
let's do what's right for the people
that we serve thank you mr president
i yield the floor
majority whip mr president i asked
unanimous consent
i ask unanimous consent that when the
senate completes its business today and
adjourn until 10 30 a.m wednesday
january 27th
further that following the prayer and
the pledge of allegiance the morning
hour be deemed expired the general
proceedings be approved to date
the time for the two leaders be reserved
for their use later in the day
and the scent being a period of morning
business with the senators permitted to
speak therein for up to 10 minutes each
it's ordered if there's no further
business to come for the senate i ask
that it stand adjourned
under the previous order
the senate is adjourned until 10 30 a.m
tomorrow morning
you